I'm going to talk to you my name's first
germ mo I'm a developer from Glasgow in
Scotland and I'm going to talk to you
about an event that was just mentioned
there that changed the world that
changed all their lives had changed your
life and Men yours and in mine and that
was this gig at the Leicester Free Trade
Hall in Manchester
it was a Friday 4th of June 1976 first
was the night the Sex Pistols played now
this is one of their first gigs outside
London they hadn't had a record eye or
anything and they're only a bit 40
people in the room but those 40 people
were inspired they were inspired by the
rawness and the the passion and the
enthusiasm that the Sex Pistols showed
that may now Bernard Sumner from Joy
Division New Yorker was there he said
this said they were terrible I thought
they were great I wanted to go up and be
terrible to know he wasn't only person
that was ill at started a band
I thought those people who were there we
got the following bands wicked joy
division new order Buzzcocks magazine
Morrissey was there started to Smith
after seeing the Sex Pistols as well as
marki Smith from the fall now Mick
Hucknall was also there from simply read
but we don't talk about those bands who
were since the part they were inspired
by the Sex Pistols but those bands also
went on to inspire other bands such as
REM ravana Radiohead's Pixies Beastie
Boys in PJ Harvey all great bands and
Coldplay but we don't talk about that
okay so I'm going to talk about
something that I'm inspired by and that
is you know JavaScript's I you know I
love it and but I've also become
recently become obsessed by something
called the Web Audio API now I don't
know if you know be the Web Audio API
it's basically like in a
high-performance way of manipulating
audio and the browser via JavaScript
we can take audio in process and do
anything we want with it no it's only
available in Chrome Safari and Mobile
Safari the moment but Firefox is looking
to implement it as soon as they can know
the way the Web Audio API works it's the
skin a concept of an autograph we're
imagine you had a guitar player but the
guitar like this one there was a strong
Accords that signal would travel down or
wire and to maybe an effects pedal like
a distortion pedal that would manipulate
the sound then go into another wire and
then maybe to the speakers in this
situation the source node is the guitar
the distortion or it is manipulating
that audio and then passing it on to our
amplifier no the other thing you can do
is that we can create audio completely
in the browser from scratch we don't
need to use an mp3 or a wire file or
anything we can just mix own from thin
air it's amazing so I'm going to show
you that just now just get the console
up the first thing we do is we create a
what's known as a context and this is
like I don't know if you have used the
canvas tag which kind of creates an area
that that you can you can draw on and
JavaScript context is a kind of similar
thing for audio it can let you it's kind
of world of soda but you can kind of
paint with sound that's terribly happy
and I would hate but that's what you can
do to create context and then from our
context we need a sound source so so in
this case I'll make a sine wave but I'll
talk a little bit Lisa what sine wave is
so we do context not create a oscillator
okay and then we have to get from our
stain wave dot connect to our speakers
in that context our destination
okay so everything's right plugged in
ready to go
the only thing we need to do know is
start the same wave off so it's dot note
on and we're going to do that after the
0 seconds so do we have audio oh it's ok
great so we should hear some beautiful
sounds Wow so we can just do my job so
that such creating its own completely in
the browser there was there was nothing
else involved in that and which I think
some you know so you might think that's
just that's just noise pleasant music
that's just a touch so do you think your
brain you know know it as some little
thing was used in one of the best
records of all time
good vibrations by the Beach Boys D is a
thing this was an actual theremin which
is slightly different than a normal
theremin with you wave your hands this
one created a sine wave like we just
heard but in a big wooden box now due to
the wonders of a technology I've been
able to shrink that big wooden box down
and to our web browser and we can see
one here so for God idea again it's very
space age so if you'll indulge me I'd
like to do a little a little performance
with the theremin with help of my
backing ok space the final frontier
these are the voyages of the Starship
Enterprise its five-year mission to
explore strange new worlds to seek out
new life and new civilizations to boldly
go where no man has gone before
okay thank you
okay so we're paired the same wave and
that's a snake round so it's just you
know a nice and even and the thing is so
sounds I just explained waves or what
sound s so does the again a happy phrase
are the vibration of the air it's this
idea the the the audio yes sorry the air
is oscillating a really high speed and
then petting your ear at like 40,000
times a second it's really quite
something but the the way we graphically
we can graphically represent sound using
waves and so different zones look
different so we see the same wave at the
top here and so then we'll get a square
wave and a triangle wave so just kind of
play one of these Zowie that's a square
wave you can hear it signs a little bit
different than before and maybe a
triangle wave it's a bit softer so the
way that's this kind of way of taking
waves and then manipulating and changing
in the shape is basically how to make a
synthesizer and that's that's how we we
do and that's why I've done here to do
the the magic of the Web Audio API and
JavaScript we've got a little keyboard
and so this one just basically contains
two different types of waves let's see
let's have a sawtooth and triangle and
you can hear
so this sustain we can put this sustain
up and that allows is the sustain is if
you play a notes that's how long that
note takes did they can add icky and
disappear so I can you know like that
hangs around for a while
whereas one really short is just so
again you know this is really easy to do
this isn't any fancy this is just a
different frequency a different Petra
saying to each type of wave and then
they're combined
so I don't know very good keyboard
player bit
so so if you want to make your own
synthesizer it's really easy
I've made this thing called QWERTY
Hancock which allows you to in started
Rafael and it basically takes allows you
to take a vector keyboard and stick it
as a front to your own your own sense
and it can take you know keyboard keys
and stuff as well as the mouse so audio
is going on that anyway so what really
excites me a bit this is from not
excited all that other stuff it's the
fact that we can now write songs in
JavaScript you know traditionally the
way people wrote songs or was you know
they would you know set up a guitar or
piano and you would write a lovely song
and they would take it into the
recording should you do and get it
recorded and you know even more recently
people have been you know rating you
know writing songs that computer but
still this idea of you know you have a
timeline that goes goes from the star
all the way to the finish and there's
all these multiple tracks and it's just
you know what we can do is we can be we
can write songs I'll just that's quotes
by the maths was Leibniz he says music
is the pleasure the human mind
experiences from counting without being
aware that it's counting and it's true
music is math and and there's nothing
better at counting than a computer
so so does anyone have idea an idea what
this does
let's hear it it's just it's just a
basic drum rock drumbeats you can see
that it's you know it's a four loop and
you know every second beat plays a kick
drum every second beat after that plays
a snare and every beat it plays a hi-hat
no I mean those play functions are
abstracting things a bit but yeah I was
using the audio that time that wasn't
synthesized so they were they were
samples of real drum kits that you have
to load these in if you're going to use
them in the Web Audio API is different
than just using an audio tag you have to
kind of pull the man via xhr and then
can it decode them to the context and
say or you have to load them into the
array buffer so again I've created that
silly little library to do this called
Abbey Lord that you can just gather a
whole bunch of a audio paths and it'll
give you a call back telling you where
they're all done in decoded and ready to
play so with that we can do something a
little more complex so we can mix those
live samples with the synth I made out
there
me being some sort of audio weskit
because I'm not this is just a nice wave
Audio API that's just this enable this
so that's fantastic
okay enough for that okay you have
written your JavaScript pets it's gonna
sell millions what do you do with it now
well I guess you just put it on your
website or you can upload it to get hub
and lay it's you know people remix it
for free you know you can create remixes
without this idea of throwing around
massive audio fails because the the fail
is already there this is what to go back
to her Punk analogy the Buzzcocks did
when they first started out they didn't
have a record label they just thought
did borrow my place borrow money from
friends and family they borrowed 500
pounds and just went into a recording
studio made a record themselves and put
themselves the meter thousand copies and
it sold it sold out almost instantly so
this idea of self-publishing you know
it's more prominent in ever and it's so
easy to do we don't even have to record
things know that we just have a file
format that just make sound that doesn't
need to be recorded so that's this idea
that I'm proposing well only really of a
name that I like for it at the moment
let's say I imagine some sort of format
like jisan
called G songs I don't have anything
more than that and so if you do want to
kind of help me with this to make a kind
of JavaScript spec for four songs on the
way it give me it I show you because all
I've got is a title okay something even
more exciting happened two weeks ago and
that is that getusermedia for audio was
enabled in the nightly build of Chrome
which means that we can now take audio
exactly what it says we can get user
media from from the user
so this allows us to take audio from a
make or elena n-- and manipulate it in
the exact same chaining method they
described before so let's give you a
little demonstration here if this works
slow like i say this is only my go
fullscreen this okay this is the
conference crusher unless the side the
the more audacious the name of any new
product the we dear it sounds okay so
don't expect anything so the first thing
when you when you use the getusermedia
you get this a little option that says
photo doe wants to use your microphone
and you'll see oops yes please
okay so we get that there's something
there yeah it's quite quiet so this is
this is a guitar there's no plugins here
is no GarageBand there's no anything
this is just a browser this is just a
normal web pages that we're now getting
so through you know so it's in it so
that's quite a clean sound right so
that's just that we the we the guitar
things through this little bit of travel
on it but what we can do is we actually
take that connect it and actually change
the we've forums that are going in okay
so we can do
so yes there's nothing more annoying
than watching someone messing around a
guitar so I spare you that so that
results just the same way before just
the sound going down bleeped and then
just the waveform it's it's just a big
array buffer that we can just flap about
any way we want we've so much control
over this so you might notice that
there's a little a back to the future
button here just want to show you how
much control we have if you have audio
again okay so no I know that how we're
doing it so I just do this that's a bit
long no let me try again okay try again
yeah it's so let's just show you how
much control we can have and that that's
all done with JavaScript I did we can
just take it somebody went and just hold
on to it for a bit and then do everyone
okay so I was really nervous about doing
this talk because I change because I'm
not typically someone who gets too
nervous but that's being GS calm for
thought these people are the best at
JavaScript whatever that means
I thought I'm going to be ridiculed
because I like semicolons and you know
and so I'm not I'm not like say I'm not
an audio expert I'm not a JavaScript eye
expert I'm you know if anyone says to me
that are an expert or anything just
gonna get a little bit sick in my mouth
you know I think it's a very arrogant
thing to claim that you're an expert and
everything because I think we can always
keep learning
no so I I was concerned I was like why
why is this bothering me because I used
to play in various bands when I was
younger and and we were rubbish but I
still got up and just jumped her own
like an idea and had a great time you
know I couldn't sing it didn't stop me
so by just chance I came across an old
notebook there was I had I used to write
lyrics then which was hilarious in
itself but I had this quartz described
at the start by David Burton and it says
the singer was talking heads and he said
the better of the singers voices the
harder it is to believe what they're
saying and that's this I think it's a
great man for anyone who doesn't believe
they're good enough for anything because
what it means to me is that I'm going to
take my weaknesses in tournament to
strength that okay I may not be the
greatest program in the world but
there's other things other outside then
and these other things I'm good at they
give the things I'm a character I'm
passionate about why I do I believe that
if you're passionate and enjoy what
you're doing it doesn't matter what the
end product is I don't make all of these
things because I thought I was going to
change the world which I'm obviously not
but I did it because I enjoyed it and I
love it and I'm passionate about it I
gave everything I've got to it I really
really enjoy it
and so that's why I believe that
javascript is a new punk rock because
you can make anything from scratch and
it doesn't matter how good it is just
that you enjoyed it so there was this
video by The Godfather of punk a eggie
pop there really I think echoes that we
I feel about what I do and what I think
we all do and you know he mentions you
mentions men but we hope he applies its
women as well and I would just like to
finish on that
you
thanks a lot
thank you
so you can follow me in these places I'm
on tenth if anyone knows any questions
yeah yeah we've any questions don't be
intimidated come on it's one over there
worst concerts I don't know what you
want to start a band with me think of a
good name we're in okay yeah just wanted
to ask really quick you're obviously not
using set time out there are you hey no
saw what the Web Audio API has it
briefly has its own time system when you
create a context that has its own
reference point that's and it does use
eight seconds but those just give you
kind of millisecond or even more than
that control over the timing of things
so what happens is you schedule things
up front you see I want all these things
to happen at these time these points in
the future so it's yeah so I've I've
actually made some things or some things
on my website the usually said time out
like a drum machine when I was being
shifted and it's like who makes a drum
machine note step it's a time out idea
you're a great talker how do you make
the Sawtooth and the square waves so
yeah so and there are they're kind of my
native concepts to the Web Audio with
API that's when we created an oscillator
at the start there that creates by
default a sine wave no we just we can
just change that type by giving a
different integer and yes so they're
kind of native to the API okay great
thank you very much thank you